one of my favorite exercises to do is
make a list of companies
or businesses that you go back to over
and over and over again
and ask yourself why for instance list
five companies
and to the right say i go to this
restaurant at least once a week why do i
go back because of dot dot dot
i go back to this fast food place every
week why do i i go to the store to shop
for clothes every month why do i go back
again i go here from groceries
why do i go back here over and over
again what is the reason
and the reason will generally be one of
these six reasons that it's going to
give you a lot of clue for your own
business
you're either going back there because
it's fast why
fast food i don't want to sit down i
just want a food i want to leave that's
all i want i don't want anything i just
want a fast service
so you go back to a place because of
fast one could be quality
what is the quality it's better material
it's better fabric
it's better whatever the quality is
better and i'm willing to spend more
money but i go back for quality
another reason could be because it's
cheap you may say hey i go to walmart
because walmart has what
everyday low prices everyday low prices
is the cheapest place
that's where i want to go to no problem
that's their play luxury
i go there because of luxury i've been
buying mercedes all my life because it's
a luxury
i like to go to this restaurant because
it's luxury i like to stay at the w
because it's luxury i like to go
because of luxury feeling that you get
another one could be user friendly i go
back to this place it's so easy i go
back to this website because it's so
easy to use
i like to use this app because it's so
easy to use user friendly it's so easy i
like iphone it's user friendly i like
this
it's user friendly right and the other
one is customer service
okay customer service now most of the
time
businesses in in we run bidding so we
have the cheapest we have the fastest we
have the best
we have the most luxury we have the most
incredible quality we have
user friendly it's so easy or best
customer service
now customer service is generally
boring and generally entrepreneurs
uh we don't necessarily pay that much
attention to customer service because
kind of like oh my gosh
customer service come on give me a break
this is boring watch this video is not
going to get that many views you'll see
it because this is not an exciting topic
but this is a very very important topic
by the time i'm done explaining this to
you
when you think about customer service
what companies do you think about watch
this
people buy bmw do you know why because
of their service
you simply drop off a bmw take another
one and you go back so bmw has a
reputation of being
incredible service now range rover may
be luxury
but it doesn't have the best service
okay
but they're known for luxury right so
what is the play
you go to another car and maybe cheap
hey i'm gonna buy a ford focus
i'm gonna buy whatever because it's
cheap there is there's things that you
can think about
tesla user friendly it's easy right
customer service nordstrom's you go to
nordstrom's
i don't care what it is one time an old
lady goes back to nordstrom's and this
is a story you can find this all over
online it's written about in books et
cetera et cetera
this person goes to nordstrom's and says
i bought this tire from here
the cashier says we don't we don't sell
tire no i bought it here
and i want to return it do you have a
receipt i don't have a receipt you know
what nordstroms did they
took the tire and the person said how
much it cost nordstrom says okay we'll
take it back
and the person when i said hey we return
the tire they're going to throw that
tire in the trash but
customer service to them is extremely
important now there are some places you
buy something from
no return policy we don't return it we
don't take it back we don't care we
don't
they don't care having one star reviews
because their policy is
i don't care to return it you buy it
you got it it's gone we're not taking it
back mattress companies sometimes do
that some of them
do certain no you've already laid down
you've already done this we're not
taking any of it back right
customer service if you think about
amazon amazon's got great customer
service i think about
uh uh what else what else would you say
customer service well i would say zappos
you know they'll
we went and got a private tour of zappos
headquarters they'll stay on the phone
with you and talk to you
they'll literally will talk to you how
things are hey let me order pizza for
you hey let me do this for you
it's constant customer service that they
that people talk about them apple's
known for great customer service
southwest airlines
when their attendants tell the jokes
that they say hey if you have to do this
make sure you put the mask on yourself
and if you have two kids choose which
one you like more these things you
hahaha it's funny
but that's customer service right you
you kind of connect with it
this is a very very very valuable way
for you to build your business with this
so now the question becomes
what is the difference between customer
service and customer experience is there
really i mean
pat what is the difference isn't it the
same thing absolutely not
why let me explain and i'll simplify it
for you and it'll stay in your mind
think at think about customer service as
reactive
and think about customer experience as
proactive
what does this mean for instance here's
customer service
thank you for calling at t how may i
help you
yes great is there any other issues that
you have
have i fulfilled your service request
that you've asked here today
okay please take this recorded call and
survey that we have going on
reactive okay customer service could be
client is upset
you handle it you react you solve all
good
customer service is thank you please
matt please put you on hold thank you
for your help thank you for listening
thank you for understanding thank you
it's customer service because customer
service could be i totally understand
where you're coming from
i totally feel your pain i'm sorry it's
apologetic it's customer service because
it's reactive to something right
customer buys here's your receipt thank
you so much
have a great day would you also like to
buy this would you like to upgrade your
service
customer service that's customer service
okay and by the way
very important customer service now a
few
are very good at customer experience
that's kind of when you go from here and
you graduate over here let me explain
what i mean by customer experience look
whatever business you run if you have
more than 100 customers
you will generally be able to tell me
that you have some vip customers
everybody has vip customers this is not
about
discrimination vip customers to american
experts it's called black card
right vip customers to american airlines
is called
executive platinum or executive or gold
members that they get priority seating
right
a vip customer to sephora makeup for
ladies could be called
you know a beauty insider right they
have this whole sephora does very well
because they have this beauty insider
group where the girls
who are part of beauty insider they get
a sample sent to them before everybody
else that's support they do phenomenal
job with this beauty insider that's
worked
very very well they get it before all
the other customers your vip
vip amazon is prime vip there's many of
them that i can give you about
what is it called vips the vips
you're hoping to get many of them here
to be converted into
vips and they only get converted here
based on what
customer experience so what is customer
experience
customer experience proactive proactive
is
the way you treat them the details
customer experience is all about details
so if i call american express black card
or if i call
visa black card mastercard black card
and they'll tell me
hey we just want to remind you you know
your anniversary is coming up your
wife's birthday is coming up any plans
we can see last time you went to bacara
hotel do you want to do the same thing
do you want me to look for something
how about you give me this afternoon let
me look for some stuff and get back to
your customer experience
then they send me an email and they call
me when is a good time for us to get on
the phone
15 minutes so let me tell you what i
found if you want to do something very
extravagant
we found this one place and we can do
this experience
and it's so unique and let me tell you
what it is and your wife's really gonna
like it tell me what things your wife
likes
experience experience okay
you know amazon could do out go out
there and find out exactly what things
you buy and see or you're buying trends
and they give you a better experience
it doesn't matter what it is it all goes
to the experience part so
or you go into apple and you talk to one
of the guys at apple and they talk to
you like you're
a regular human being you don't feel
like you're scripted
too much although they have a script as
well that they got to follow but it's
just talking to you
zappos is the same way they're talking
to they're listening to you tell me
about you how's you how's your day
you don't hear too many regular customer
service people
companies saying so tell me about your
day like think about that small little
slight question that
you call somewhere you call chase for
customer service yes i'm trying to
handle this thing then they said okay
great let me place you on hold
let me see what i can do what's your
things on what's your did you have a
case summer for this
okay thank you okay have a great day
bye-bye done instead
okay thank you uh patrick david thank
you so much by the way patrick how was
your day today
and i'm gonna say whatever i'm gonna say
i'm gonna give them
it's okay it's great and then i'm gonna
ask what how was your day oh my day is
great thank you for asking
by the way thank you for your loyalty i
can see here you've been with us for 10
years
uh we appreciate your loyalty with us
hey somebody appreciates my loyalty i'm
a loyal human being
no problem i've been a loyal customer
we're proud to put i've been an american
express
card holder since 1998 you know whatever
it is
loyalty right i appreciate you thank you
this goes to here
this goes to here and the more you can
take people from here to here
the better off you're going to be with
your business let me help you think
about it maybe in a way that'll make
sense to you
uh a little bit more that'll make sense
to you a little bit more and i'll wrap
up this episode
is this okay so when it comes down to
the dating game okay when it comes down
to the dating game just think about it
this way
there are a lot of people that it's just
boom they want to go out and they want
to be promiscuous
all good it's a philosophy you want to
do that that's good
in business if you treat your customers
like that
or even women like that your reputation
spreads if you treat
customers like that or anybody like that
reputation spreads
and it's not always the best reputation
to not treat people properly
so then there is you know just one night
stand philosophy
then there's dating philosophy then
there's marriage philosophy
your vips are marriage your vips are
marriage
your vips are people that go from dating
to marriage they're kind of trying your
product they like it
great wow they treat me so well i want
to marry these guys
and i want to go there regularly and
then i want to tell other people
they become your best recruiters vip
members become your best recruiters best
recruiters
they recruit for you for free all that
million dollar ad
on tv that you're trying to do or
whatever it is you're trying to you
don't have to do it
because they're doing it for you for
free if you convert people into vips
they are so valuable this is why some
companies
there's nothing different zappos does
except for the fact that
they create incredible customer service
they don't make shoes
they don't make shoes zappos doesn't
make shoes they're not toms they don't
make shoes
it's service it's purely service for
them they give incredible service
they send you a return you don't have to
pay for the return you don't like it
they'll pay for it
it's purely a service game they're not
playing the cheap game they're playing a
service game with you
it's so valuable and then all of a
sudden zappos get valued at you know it
was bought for a couple billion dollars
whatever the number is
tony shea is a customer service guy so
i know a lot of times especially
startup entrepreneurs or people that
you want to become a millionaire
yesterday you know i get messages oh i
want to be a billionaire by the time i'm
35 years old
it's great you know maybe don't tie it
to believe me if you tithe for more
people being happy doing business i had
a conversation this morning with a
friend of mine
who's one of our executives in our
company uh land he's a doctor dr cooper
he and i we're having a conversation
together
and he said pat you know i'm sitting and
somebody came and told me something
about
why i chose to work with you and he says
all i
said is my entire experiences of working
with you how it's been and he's going
into this whole story of what he's
telling me on this call we're having
early early call that we were having
here this morning which led was a
fascinating call
i'm sure he appreciates that call but
that's a shout out to len out there he
just had his 20-year anniversary and his
wife tasha
so we're having this call together and
all he was telling me
while i'm listening is our experience
together why is he still here he left a
six figure job to come up he was a
principal youngest principal
in san bernardino valley area but he
came because of the
experience he had and he is my customer
now we've become very good friends so
it's past a vip
and the more we have of that that we
treat people properly
the more they tell everybody your
business gets stronger
you can't have this you know wham bam
type of a mentality and your business
ain't gonna grow because you're not
paying attention to your
customers so go back again the initial
exercise
make a list of the five businesses that
you go to regularly and ask yourself
why do you go back you will be amazed
how
all of them will generally have one of
these things
here one of these things here now you
may say convenience it's very close
that's part of fast
so no any of that stuff that you write
down is going to be part of one thing
and then for your own business ask
yourself what can i do
to take my customer service to a whole
different level to add customer
experience to my
business and to give birth to more vip
customers
and what do i categorize as a vip
customer
for me what do you categorize as a vip
customer for you
and what can you do to promote more
people from regular to vip customers
and that in itself is going to make you
a ton of money depending on how big you
want to build it will do you very very
well growth wise
word of mouth people wanting to do
business with you regularly over and
over and over again so
that's my message today for you on
customer service
and customer experience mario where's
our pillow here do we have our pillow
do we have our pillow i can no longer
say 100 000 subs because we are now at
000 subs what is exciting is we've
already gotten many hundreds of emails
of people that said they're making that
video
on why i love valuetainment and if you
don't know about the video we just
crossed a hundred thousand subs
and mario asked me to uh uh put a
announce a contest to be able to
privately
mentor three of you here in my office in
dallas texas for three hours to go
through your business plan and put a
strategy
plan together for 2017. we're planning
on doing it sometime in the month of
december
but you'll need to submit a three-minute
video and all the details
let's put a link somewhere here where
people can't see it you can go to
patrickbetdavid.com as well
boom and you'll see the detail as well
it's a hundred thousand subscriber uh
celebration contest
you can find find out more details about
that but if you haven't subscribed yet
to the channel please do so
click on the link below here and if you
have any questions about customer
service
and customer experience good catch post
your comments
and thoughts on the bottom take care
everybody bye-bye